but most important when i'm looking for
early stage startup which
this is the area what i'm doing the most
important thing is the entrepreneurs
and the entrepreneurs i look for vip
teams what is vip v8 vip
stands for v which is the values what
drives
the background and the values of the
founder itself
i which is the intent what he wants to
do what is an intention
and then the p which is the plan how we
want to achieve it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
we all want to make a strong impact and
it's a little ambiguous what that
actually means and how to actually
measure the impact
today i'm joined by ophir azuri head of
technology investments at gender
investment group
and we pretty much talked exactly about
this challenge
ophir is a technology and impact
investor and serves as the head of
technology investments at gundir
investment group
focusing on early stage startups within
the areas of ai
sas digital health and corporate sw
some of its portfolio ventures include
companies such as yotpo
mobilei neutrino any word nym softwave
ecopia ilios health and others
of zuri welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you
i'm pretty good thank you for having me
michael of course are you calling from
gandir
right now in israel yeah actually i'm
within the gandhir office which is
and there is a family office in which
i'm uh taking part of as
the technology leader in the entire
investment area so
this is where i reside most of the day
wonderful er you know a lot of people
you know when they
when i ask them to give you know this
one sentence brief
and generally i think of that you know
when they send me their bio i look at
this first sentence and i see okay
how do they describe themselves and one
of the things that i noticed is that you
immediately said
that uh you know ophir is a technology
and impact
investor and that is not a it's
it's not a very trivial thing to to pass
by
and i think that that was also a great
segue into you know
to talking you know about something that
is a little different than than what i'm
used to
hearing about but but it is equally as
exciting as anything else with this idea
of impact investing so feel
what why do you call yourself an impact
investor what does that mean
so actually this kind of combination
started when i uh
11 years ago when i started to advise
gender on different type of
investment mostly around the tech area
so gandhi is a family office
in which there is certain amount of
values that it
employs throughout the different
activities starting from the gandhi
foundation which is a foundation that
helps young adults in israel
and inside of that they're doing
different stuff on different different
type of investment so as a combination
of this kind of values
we managed to create an impact
investment room which is a virtual room
but actually combine the value and
saying that not doing only money from
general investment and then putting in
philanthropy
try to integrate this into something
more like a whole process that
combines your values and putting it into
work so
throughout the years in my technology
investment i started to work with a lot
of different startups
and i found out that a lot of different
teams that they cannot
take themselves or call themselves like
impact but actually within the dna of
these kind of teams they really want to
do good
so this kind of combination created me
taking the role of
okay what kind of impact investment
within the tech oriented areas we can do
so i started to work with a lot of
different uh startups starting with
companies such as neutrino
we started to do like uh find the food
uh
behavioral food consumption profile
of each and every user and took it and
turn it into something that is much more
valuable for diabetics so actually it
can
tell you exactly what kind of food
you're gonna consumption
and then based on that reduce the
fluctuation of sugar consumption for any
kind of diabetic patient
so it created a whole different layer of
impact for this kind of
uh a patient and and managed to reduce
the sugar level which is really really
impactful
and a year after that they're just being
bought by uh
by medtronic and created a total team
that handles the entire diabetic areas
for the aui
and app related stuff for medtronic so
this kind of
situation where both you have an impact
for the product
and also for the company i always divide
them into two because they're different
kind of companies
so by defining it also the product
impact and the company impact
you can integrate different layers of
impact that both the founders and the
company itself can provide to the
society
so this kind of combination between the
technology and impact tech
created something that we are working
all around from
philanthropy to a regular impact to a
financial esg
investment to impact tech right
and but it sounds to me that technology
investment
investing you know has its challenges
and a lot of people have been
working to overcome those challenges
with different matrix and different due
diligence processes to try and mitigate
the risks
of of a technology team not fulfilling
up to its potential
how do you go ahead and mitigate those
risks when it comes to impact
so it's different types of risks there's
different ways to measure it of course
some of them i imagine aren't even
analytical so how do you even go about
in trying to measure
you know both impact and the potential
risk
so first i think you use the best
important word which is measure
because i think to do an impact
investment you need to measure the
impact
not just uh say it in a pitch or within
a presentation because we don't want to
guarantee everything we're doing just
with the right impact
but most important when i'm looking for
early stage startup which
this is the area what i'm doing the most
important thing is the entrepreneurs
and the entrepreneurs i look for vip
teams what is vip v8 vip stands for v
which is the values
what drives the background and the the
values of the founder itself
i which is the intent what he wants to
do what is an intention
and then the p which is the plan how we
want to achieve it
so combining this stuff along with the
different types of
entrepreneurs diversity is very very
important the integration the
combination and the interaction within
the entrepreneurial team
is really really important for achieving
something that has
concrete impact measurement and also
business
and financial achievement so it's really
really important to work with these
entrepreneurs to understand this kind of
intent and turn it into a
really plan that can be measured right
and so you you've already got a chance
to take a part in
in some incredible investments say just
a few of them yotzpo mobile neutrino any
word
nym eliot's health and more
so how do you how do you even go about
and you know
do do you notice different patterns
within you as you're trying to observe
these different opportunities
things that you're sort of converging on
different questions that you're asking
on the get go because you're you're
talking about early stage
a lot of these companies are you know
today they're phenomenal and today
everybody knows them but
i'm sure back then it wasn't that
obvious to go into their investment
totally so again the entrepreneur is the
most important thing but more than that
within the
impact area the sdgs are one of the most
important thing that you can use as
an investor because as an investor we
work very very solidly because
according to draws he wanted to say to
me okay
i'm invested in an area that is
sustainable economics or sustainable
uh um um i can give you one example
which is very very interesting
which is the ileos ilios is a digital
health company
and they started to say okay we have the
um psychotherapists that working with
different type of
patients now today this the entire
efficacy of this treatment is
is being handled like in the early 50s
that's it's just sitting
next to each other he writes down on a
piece of paper the entire summary
and none of this interaction are being
measured
or getting any insight regarding
emergency eye issues or alerts
how it is being done that did it employ
the entire techniques that he wanted to
employ and
this save a lot of operation time to
make sure that the entire session has
been really efficient
so a lot of different kind of metrics
that can put inside and save
a lot of time efficient efficiency of
the treatment and give
access to a lot of different patients
that cannot be exposed because of this
zoom
everything is much more access today so
there's a lot of different aspect that
i'm measuring again
the founders the topic that they choose
how they're gonna deal
how they're gonna work with the company
and its entire stakeholders
do they relate to the the suppliers how
do you see the physical environment
so there's a lot of different aspect
that i'm looking at again in early
stages the early signs
if you want to measure it if you want to
achieve it and how you're going to do it
and this is why where i started to work
with them
right tell me a little bit about good
day investment company and the
israeli forum for impact economy uh both
of those sound like fascinating
organizations
and that that are also revolving around
this this nice idea of impact
so actually good day is a is a private
company that my wife and i started
to work towards with variety from uh
philanthropy to advanced philanthropy
such as the
impact investing and uh social
investment bonds which is we can take a
moment to discuss that
because uh social impact bonds are very
very interesting stuff that started with
ronald klein
uh and and he wanted to achieve
themes that usually are being
philanthropic if you want to help
unserved communities or you want to help
a prisoner from getting back to prison
so they took this kind of
thematic area in israel it already begun
five of them
social investment bonds and for example
we were part of the
diabetes prevention in israel so you're
taking a a
and it can be like i think it was 700
people
that most probably poised to be in
diabetic condition in a year or so
you change your entire habits and
italian wellness and and lifestyle
and by doing that we actually giving the
payers which is the between the social
security or even the hmos
you're giving them value because and
instead of paying a lot of money
they managed to keep this kind of
patient potential diabetic patient
and and making sure they will not be
diabetic so
this kind of operation allows the
investor of this kind of thematic
uh issue to get back their money
but not only get back they also based on
success
and this is the most important thing
that paid by success
if we manage to bring a lot of people
back from
prediabetic into a really regular
lifestyle
we manage to help a lot achieve a social
business goal
but gain even a revenue on that so it's
unheard of in the philanthropic there
are different type of new existing
models
that really help and drive the entire
social impact area
into areas that can be like a general
financial outcome
so this is something that really really
drives me
to look for these kind of models and and
this is just the beginning
right because i think traditionally
people observe these models of
of philanthropy social impact they don't
usually align with
you know financial returns they they are
they are more concerned with how do we
just deploy money to make a positive
impact and
and and but that's that's not
sustainable and that's not scalable
and then from what i'm hearing from you
by finding this win-win situation and
this
economically viable model that makes it
that is what that is what can drive the
real impact
totally i'll give you another example
there is something called isa which is
income share agreement take a look
for example student that cannot lives in
the peripheral area and
cannot really access the entire high
tech society
you need to do some kind of transition
in his career
so putting i don't know ten thousand
dollars fifteen thousand dollars on a
boot camp
cost him a lot and he cannot really
afford it but
if we're gonna take as investor the risk
from him and say to him
we will take care of the payment but
you're gonna pay from success only
meaning that if we manage to increase
your salary more than ten thousand
dollar currently you're being paid five
thousand dollars
but if you're gonna pay more than ten
thousand dollars or more than that
you're gonna pay only from success so
just a percentage
of your uh uh future income
so again we managed to create social
mobility
and create something that usually and
philanthropy is just being on the best
effort level
but here it's success-based effort this
is something that we really work on
and we're currently being involved in
another project in israel
taking the druze area into putting them
into high tech as well
wow okay so it's something we can have a
full episode there just like
give me a few sentences though on your
work you don't work with that population
because
you know obviously in the times that we
live in and and seeing the fragmentation
of our society which is so heartbreaking
on one end
hearing about these types of initiatives
uh whether it's small or large scale
those are always
extremely uplifting so share with me a
little bit about what you're doing over
there
yeah so actually it's a social fund in
israel is a creating a new
uh uh social investment bonds that take
this kind of community that usually
does not go to the high-tech area
they're more like going to a specific
areas that are less in the high tech not
exposed to the haiti community and a lot
of different companies that within the
haifa area and this kind of area say
why do i don't have druze in my company
so let's try to do the best and bring
them on so we need to bring world models
we need to get them
educated we need to help them getting
the right cvs
and work them their own interviews so
the lot of different stuff that need to
be
handled in order to make them inside and
again diversity is the most important
thing
to create a real companies real
companies that thrive and
and get their business results corrected
so this is one of the examples that i'm
really excited about
that we're working i think that no no i
think that's really really cool and tell
me a little bit about the israeli forum
for impact economy
yeah so it's a the israel impact economy
is a form that started in israel a
couple
of years ago that tried to combine the
entire
areas of regulation and and and
and different types of deal flow and the
impact tech all these areas
to promote them in israel and create a
viable society a viable economy
for this kind of activities it can be
working with different pension funds to
allow their own
uh savers to have an esg related
uh areas or even
a truck that they can put their money
and not only their
their exact uh financial outcome
also their pension esg related topics i
want to be involved in areas
that really match my values so today we
can start to do it
throughout the entire areas of our
activities
so this is a real thing that we think
that again millennials are the most
important areas in this kind of puzzle
they really want to work in places that
serve their own values
and this is we believe they're going to
be a change it's not only in the esg
that really took off
during the entire covet and you know a
lot of in a financial area esg related
stuff are really booming
but also the next step going to be
within the pension fund
will be on each and every topic that
they are doing and for sure in impact
tech is the most important area because
erg for me
is the new dna of the company if you
know how to treat your employees
your suppliers your entire area and and
your physical
environment this is where you're gonna
employ and use a lot of new
workers that would like to work with you
and you achieve higher business and less
greasy in regulation
so there are a lot of different benefits
to do esg
as your dna not only for the pitch and
again the presentation
but to create real value for the company
and reduce risk
this is why i think this is going to be
booming in the next few years right and
i think that you know
what the place we're at today and what
i'm observing here is that
there was a trend where it was obviously
becoming sexier
and more you know more encouraging to
join an investment opportunity when you
know that the company
that you're that you're looking at is
trying to make some sort of positive
impact but
so that's how it started to make itself
onto the pitch like you know the ai went
on to the pitch
but now when you have these different
models that are actually saying okay we
can actually go and tangibly make it
happen
and we can tangibly explain how it's
possible to
to build the dna of a company through
those types of
of ideas that then it becomes actually
real and
and as an impact investor i'm sure that
you can very easily today differentiate
between those that are
that are you know saying it and those
that are actually doing it yeah and
and i think that that's probably one of
the hardest things that that you would
have to
be able to do as an impact investor but
i think nevertheless
it's extremely exciting and i'm
extremely excited for myself as i
continue to be thinking about what types
of things i would want to be working on
they're coming to talk to you and and
trying to understand okay how can i
actually be very intentional about
about how to get started with these
things as the dna
as as what you're saying and i think
that you're always amazing michael
i know you and you are the best guy for
do it and again it's work in progress
the entire measurement is keep on and
progressing
and we work hand in hand to make sure
it's going to be applied for the
impact tech area wonderful okay ophel
are you ready for some fun questions
but i want to ask you a thing before
that please i think it's around the 400
stuff that you are doing the session or
something
what is your input about all this
session give me five minutes about
yourself and how you feeling throughout
the like
being an anchor usually you're just
interviewing everyone
but i want to hear your view i this is
the first time somebody asked me a
question on 20 minute leaders now i can
feel what it's like to be
to be in your seat i think that you know
it's hard to summarize
you know these uh 400 episodes it's hard
to summarize you know
everything but what i think what i can
say you know looking back is
getting so excited about you know every
person coming in
and and for 20 minutes trying to distill
you know
what they're passionate about and what
they've been thinking about for years
and sometimes in those 20 minutes i find
that it ca it can
even you know come up as simple or it's
or somewhat
of trivial trivial or obvious but then
when i actually think about the journey
that that person had to go through to
come up with these
with these insights that they truly
believe in that's the inspiring part for
me it's understanding that the journeys
are much
greater than what it was than what they
maybe seem to be
in these in these 20 minutes and you
know i think that
i'm learning that you can't skip over
the journeys just because i'm learning
these lessons here doesn't mean that i
that i can forego those experiences
where i'll learn them and so i'm excited
to mainly throw myself into the deep
water
with all these insights and trying to
trying to claim them for myself
through real tangible experiences i
think that i
had the pleasure of hearing about a lot
of different things what that i
shouldn't be doing
or different failures that people had
along the way that i can try to overcome
you know but when it comes to the things
that people get really excited about
i think that that's something that i'll
have to discover and i'm excited to
continue discovering them for another
400 episodes at least
uh but but but it's been it's it's been
a roller coaster
hearing uh hearing you know why people
do what they do and what people are
truly passionate about because of
you know in these 20 minutes you know
you you've been working on this for
years and you work so hard and you meet
so many companies and you've been
adjusting your thinking
over the years and i come here and
within you know 20 minutes try to
distill your thought process
into this very short time frame and so
you're telling me you know
if you're in 2021 what do you believe in
and
and i think it's just it's so awesome
for me to know
that this is just you know at one
junction of the journey
and you know when we'll do an another
episode a year from now and i very much
hope will do
yeah it'll be a little bit of a
different feel and and it's going to be
you know this
continuous improvement and continuous
thinking process
that i that i get excited about michael
i
i totally agree that again a lot of
insight in your session but most
important this is the people business
and again the technology is riding aside
us but again it's all about the people
what drives them
and where they are passionate so i think
you're doing a great job a hundred
percent well thank you for thank you for
taking the interviewer seat
for a few minutes i really appreciate it
i'm going to reclaim it now
because i have some fun questions for
you that i can't let you go without
uh so we'll start off easy favorite
subject in school
favorite subject in school actually
[Music]
i think the most important in school
that i had
is going to the youth environment and
youth movement
this is the most important stuff that i
did and
really doing my best to be the best over
there to be an instructor
and and and getting the time with a lot
of the guys
this is the most important thing being
with people
i love it one of your role models in
life
real or fake
um regarding impact really i think what
ronald cohen
is doing in the past few years is really
driving
an entire scene into a new area
and i think is one of the the ones that
really leads us
and in putting the vision and we try to
follow in
and accomplish different types of areas
in our
small footsteps but really i like what
he's doing he's really a role model for
me
i love it and a last question
three words you would choose to describe
yourself any three words
um i think
again it's different it's hard what
people would say about me but i think
i'm a trustworthy person
i always being discreet with with
people's
own beliefs and and their own secrets
and most important i try to be candid
and stay
saying frankly what i think in the first
or second
session not to drive them around you
know around the bush and
and let them understand what else
saying exactly what they think and try
to be ethically with business with them
i think that it ties nicely back to what
you said before it's a people business
and and so i'm not surprised that those
three words exemplify
relationships that you maintain with
other people and i can definitely
see that come through in these 20
minutes and for me getting to know you
ophir thank you very very much this was
wonderful
continue doing a fantastic impact
investing and
and i can't wait to continue working
together thank you
thank you very much michael for the
opportunity have a good one
thank you
[Music]